[Music]
it's in cities where most of the
information we have about black and
ethnically diverse people is gathered
but what if you live outside the big
cities
where you're hidden from the studies and
the surveys
louisa is one of nearly two million
black people who live in the uk
but one of only about a thousand living
in somerset
her experience is unlikely to be
captured in any study systemic racism is
obviously a massive problem and that
permeates
sort of all areas of society no matter
where we live but i think here in the
west country
i think we have a particular culture of
institutionalised racism
and within that culture racism doesn't
get challenged very much
and when people do challenge it or do
speak out they can be then abused or
victim blamed
and then sort of experience more
discrimination if you like
anecdotally racism is worse in rural
areas
that's certainly the experience of
somerset pastry chef waheed
no studies examine this but data shows
you're many more times likely to be
stopped and searched if you're black
living in the west country than in
london i've been told to
go back to where i come from a few times
i get lots of stairs from people
uh i've been racially abused
i'd say a couple of times obviously the
random stop in searches because
obviously there's not many people that
look like me out here so
um you get disproportionately stopped
yeah yeah it's happened to me about 12
or 13 times in my
lifetime here the different experiences
of people from ethnic communities living
in the countryside
is just one example of data that's
missing and if there are gaps in
knowledge
there will be gaps in policy which is
why the center on the dynamics of
ethnicity
is commissioning the biggest ever study
to find out
what's missing it will cover topics and
aspects of life
that are relatively unknown about for
minority communities
such as political attitudes financial
circumstances health and mental health
and well-being religious and ethnic
identities
there are some huge data gaps for the
last 10 years for instance the nhs
has not measured mental health and how
it intersects with ethnicity
but 10-year-old data suggests that black
people
are five times more likely to suffer a
severe
mental health illness than white people
white is held up as the norm
then you do grow up with a with you know
distorted sense of self and
have problems with identity and it's
definitely impacted by mental health
it may be subtle but cumulative the
things that impact
on why minority groups have different
outcomes
and experiences to the majority small
things such as
finding a slavery family memorialized
on the walls of your local church i came
to this beautiful church because i love
churches
and i found this memorial to azeri penny
and one of the things that said on it on
there was that he was benefactor to all
men and that made me feel quite upset
because i've done quite a lot of
research into the pinney family and i
know about their
slave trading activities plantation
owner john pinney said of slaves
surely god ordained them for use and
benefit for us
it's all in the past but many feel those
inequalities haven't fully
balanced out and only by knowing and
understanding the problem
can we try to solve it jason farrell sky
news